Hi, I'm Brian Naughton. I'm, I'm a
scientist at 23andMe and I'm from Dublin, Ireland.
>> So after dropping the DNA sample in the mail, we don't see anything until
we get to our results. what happens to that sample once we drop it in
the mail? Where does it go? Where does it end up? So your sample actually
gets shipped to our lab in Los Angeles
where it gets processed. There are four major
components to that. It starts with
DNA extraction, then amplicfication of the DNA,
then hybridization, and finally analysis of the data to make sure it's good.
>> Okay, great about how long does that process take to do all those steps?
>> So if you take all of the steps, and you did
them end to end, it would probably take three days or so.
>> Mm-hm.
>> A lot of the process is just waiting for the equipment to become
available because of volume.
>> I see. What, of all those sort of four processes,
which of those is the most time intensive of all of them?
>> The most time-intensive is the hybridization stuff, which happens
overnight. Amplification also happens overnight, though. So there are two major
parts where we have to leave the DNA for a
while, and come back to it, so it has time to
>> about
what what, I mean I'm curious. What's the
most expensive part of the Of the process.
>> So that the chip and the reagents are going to be expensive part
of the process. I mean, by the chip, you also get the reagents that
sort of like the chemicals that you need to run the chip. the other expensive
components are probably labor, obviously, because we
actually need to hire what's called high-complexity
staff to run our process. It's a CLS staff.
and then the, the rest is actually fairly inexpensive.
>> What are the are there
any international restrictions, like obviously I'm, I'm
guessing if the lab time only takes, you know, like you said, three days,
but, you know, longer if you're processing multiple samples. You know, it should
take a lot longer for any international
people, who want to have this service done?
>> So the lab process
doesn't take longer, obviously the shipping is an issue
and shipping can be expensive if you're coming from Asia
to California that's part of the reason why we want
to add another lab actually just to help with that.
>> Uh-huh.
>> There's also issues with exporting DNA from certain
countries, so China and India specifically have laws around
what DNA you are allowed to export out of
that country. So that, that plus other regulations regarding
biological specimens mean that it's actually quite difficult
to add another country to our list of countries.
>> Tell us a bit more aboutthe
DNA extraction step. What actually happens, you get
the, the DNA or the saliva sample in the lab, what do you do to get
the DNA out? DNA extraction is a very, you know normal thing that happens in
labs all over the world. There's nothing special
about who, how we do our DNA extraction.
But the process is really trying to separate the DNA in the nucleus of the cell
from the proteins and other components of the
cell that other wise be in the way.
>> I see, and how much DNA do you
get out of the saliva sample that someone sends in?
>> It's actually very variable. So depending on the person we can
get anywhere from ten micrograms to over a hundred micrograms of DNA.
>> And does most of
that variation happen just based on the number of
cells that were in that spit sample or saliva
sample? We think so, but we actually don't have
very good information on that. We know that some
people's saliva is more watery than other people, and
we know that, for example, infants do not often
give us good data, and we think that's partially
because of the wateriness of the, of that saliva.
>> Well, for those people who might be wondering, you know,
what kinds of cells do you actually getting in, in
my spit? What, what, what, what are the actual cells that
And the and white blood cells are the other major component.
>> Now, I, I do floss and brush my teeth, but I know that I'm sure I have some
kind of bacteria or germs in there. Even still is that a concern at
all, worrying about sort of having other non-me
DNA in my spit sample? Again, it's not something
we worry about too much. We know that
people have a lot of bacteria in their mouths,
and we know that from person to person there's a huge variability
in the composition of those bacteria. But for amplification we are happy
to amplify up all of your human and bacterial DNA. And then
let the sequencing or genotyping process sort out the human from the bacterium.
>> I see. So, as long as it's human it's good. But does that mean, like,
I, you know I shouldn't go kiss anybody right before I, I, I give my DNA sample?
>> For the 23andMe
test, we actually collect two milliliters of saliva from you. Which
doesn't sound like a lot, but it can take up to
five to 10 minutes to fill that. That's a lot of
saliva. You have to be kissing a lot to make a difference.
>>
[LAUGH]
So when you finish the first step, the DNA extraction, you essentially have
taken our sample and like you said, sort of purified the DNA from
[INAUDIBLE]
gotten rid of all the other stuff, the
proteins, the other molecules that might be part
of cells and other kinds of contaminants. And
you pretty much have just a purified DNA product.
>> Exactly.
>> Now is, is that enough already to do what you
want to do with it or what do you have to do next?
>> Not really. It's common in many situations like this to want to amplify the
DNA. So you always want to give yourself
the best opportunity to sequence what's in there.
And the easiest way to do that is to take
the DNA you got and amplify it or copy it
as many times as you can so that you just
have enough signal that you make it easy on yourself.
>> I see. So when you say you're, you're amplifying or you're,
you're making copies I mean, are you controlling kind of how many copies
you make or you just, you know, you're making like ten more,
20 more, you know, 100 more? How does that work? It's not tightly
controlled, but, in essence, at the end of the process, you end up with a
thousandfold enrichment of the DNA. So you really end up with a lot more DNA.
>> So, do you end up with DNA leftover? You know, after
you're done with the procedure, you actually have leftover DNA for, for people?
>> Sometimes, we do. but usually, we store your DNA in its
In the saliva form, so that we're going back to the original copy.
One issue with amplification is that, every time you
copy just like in DNA replication in humans, there
is a possibility for error. So those errors could
compound if you keep copying the copy. Just like Xeroxing
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Now, we have our extracted DNA sample that's
been amplified, so we have enough of our sample
to do something with. are we ready to go
sequence it now? Is that what we're going to do?
>> So, the process that your DNA undergoes at 23andME is
a little different to sequencing. It's called chip hybridization or genotyping.
>> And so, how does this differ from sequencing? What's the difference
between sequencing, and sort of, what
you mentioned as sort of chip hybridization
for, for genotyping? So, if you can think of
sequencing as just reading the genome from beginning to
end almost, you want to know every single letter and
what it is. With genotyping we actually decide beforehand, which
parts of the genome, which letters are interesting to
us, and then we specifically look at those letters
with the knowledge that, these are the letters that
maybe cause diseases or are associated with Some trait that
we have.
>> I see. So you have to actually put a lot of
thought into it before hand as to sort of know exactly which positions,
which bases, which letters your interested in. How many letters, do you
actually or how many bases do you look at in an individual sample?
>> So we look at about a million on the current
[UNKNOWN]
chip. that means that, when you get your results back from us,
you can download a million different calls, or base pairs from us.
>> Sequencing sounds like it gives you a lot
more information. what are the prohibitive aspects of sequencing? Why
doesn't 23andMe do sequencing? Yeah, sequencing is definitely the future
of this field and we, we're definitely interested in sequencing
when it gets cheap enough. But the main advantage of
genotyping is cost. so we know that to get the same
results that we get with the 23andMe chip we would have
to charge at least ten times more with the sequencing product.
>> Wow.
>> Probably a lot more.
>> Oh, I see.
>> Genotyping has other advantages as well. We, because
you genotype using the process of hybridization, you actually get
a lot of different shots on go, if you
like. You get to hybridize different molecules many times
>> Mm-hm. And you get the, the sum of all of those, or
the, the average of all of those weeds. You get a lot of
information compiled into one data point.
With sequencing, you might actually miss the
part of the genome you were interested in, and that could be a problem.
>> I see. So, in a way, you kind of
have higher confidence, even though you have maybe
more limited information in the end. You, you
have a higher confidence about the actual, you
know, letter or base result for that position.
>> Exactly. And some people describe genotyping as almost like
single based sequencing, where we're sequence, we're sequencing hundreds of
thousands of molecules on each part of the chip. So
there's an advantage there that's hard to replicate in sequencing.
>> Tell us a bit more
about how this sort of chip piratization works for people who are unfamiliar. I
hear chip, and I. Well, sometimes I think potato chip. But I know in this case,
we're probably talking about something more like maybe a computer chip. How does
this work exactly? Yeah, so the chip is really a glass slide that contains
an array of DNA. And those, and the DNA is bound to glass beads,
that are, scattered, on a, on a regular
pattern on the, on the chip. So then that
DNA is designed by us. To bind to the
parts of the genome we're interested in, it's the
process I talked about a minute ago, and it
comes together through the process of base pairing, just
like double helix base pairing. And then either you
have, let's say an a at postion The position
we're interested in, or a g. And depending
on which of those two you have, will either
light up green or light up red on the chip, at a specific position on the chip.
>> I see, so you essentially have sort of a
discreet, or quantum unit, for every little DNA molecule that
you're testing, you get a little signal that says, oh
you have an a or you have a g here.
>> Exactly. And because humans are deployed, you'll also get situations
where you have A and G, one from mother, one from father. So then, what we
see at that position on the chip is red and green or kind of a yellow
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Oh, that's really clever. So that, and it
allows you to easily distinguish any given position that you're
looking at. Yeah, so when we get the data
at 23andMe we actually can plot it on a simple
xy plot with red on the y axis and green on the sorry, on the x axis. And then
we'll see three clusters of people who are AA,
AG and GG because those are the three possible situations.
for disposition in your genome. Then we can say, well if you're in
this cluster, its because of the process
called clustering, and you're AG, and if
your in this cluster, then you're AA. So there's a kind of a simple
analysis problem at the end of the, at the end of the output there.
>> I see it sounds like you're
actually using sort of, the information from pooled
set of individuals, that you know, you're sort
of looking, and So even though an individual
call maybe difficult to know where on that graph
you're, you're placed. If you use sequestering like you said,
you can more readily identify. Oh, you're part of
this group. So you're AA, not AG kind of thing.
>> That's exactly right. And there are also situations you can imagine
where we get even more information, so, you could imagine a situation where
you have a deletion of the part of the geneome we're interested
in. Then what you will see is a new cluster another cluster of
[UNKNOWN]
three with lower intensity because there is less signal there because there
are fewer DNA molecules. So then a new cluster could emerge and
it could be as infrequent as one in thousand people or one
in hundred thousand people. But we will see a nucleus of samples there.
>> Now, in, in lesson two of, of
our course, we actually talked about the first time
there about the idea of base pairing. And
we learned about the base pairing rules and, and
how things fit together. but what I find really
interesting is the idea that in, in a double stranded
DNA, you know, you have all these letters matching with
each other. Is, is what you're telling is the idea
that a single nucleotide variant is just one letter
change here? That if one letter doesn't match, that essentially
what's happening is that, the, the strand can't actually hybridize
completely. It can't base pair completely, and that's why you,
you don't see the signal for one, but you
do for another? Is that, essentially what''s going on?
>> It's something very close to that. So
what we expect is that all of the letters
leading up to the letter we're interested in will
bind. And like you say, if there is a,
an error there, one difference, then it won't bind,
or it will bind weakly. So the signal will
be weak. But then, the specific letter we're interested
in, which will kind of come out one more
base, has, there's a pool of a's, g's,
c's and t's floating around that can bind there.
>> Mhm.
>> Or not. They'll only bind. If it's the correct base pair
>> And it's unoccupied.
>> And it's unoccupied. Then, we'll see
the extension happen. The reaction that leads
to the color, you know, the color that we can see in our imaging system.
>> That's great. And so essentially you have this,
you said the chip is a slide, and you're looking at
a million bases in this one little chip, this one little space?
>> Yeah. So there, even more than that. There's more than a million
beads per chip because it's better to read the same variant many, many times.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Just to get a good average signal.
>> Mm Hm. the reason for that, is that if
your in the corner, or maybe you'll get slightly different
optics, cause the cameras looking at the center of the chip,
or so, or something like that. So you just want some redundancy.
>> I see.
>> So it's a more then ten million beads per chip. And that process has been
improving over the years the density of the,
of the chips has been increasing, a lot.
>> How many chips, so, I mean, do you, have
you always use the same chip, or How do you
make changes, you know, if there's a new, I guess,
I don't know, a new trait, or a new a
new SNV that you've become interested in. Are
you able to change your chips, so you can
look at that? Yes. We update the chip approximately
every 18 months. we're on the third iteration right
now, and we're constantly looking for a new variance
to add to the chip to improve the performance
of it. So you can imagine then, if there's
a paper published that says, this mutation in this
gene causes a disease. And it, you know, it's very interesting to go
and find that out. We can design what we call a, a probe
for that. Just a base, the sequence of DNA is attached to the
glass bead, and we make sure it's on the next iteration of the chip.
>> You mentioned that the hybridization process is sort of
the, the longest part. you said it happens over, overnight?
>> Yeah.
>> what, I mean for those of us, I mean we've learned
conceptually about base pairing, but any technical insight you might
have. I mean what's, why is this an overnight process?
>> Essentially it just takes time for the DNA in your saliva,
in the extracted saliva sample to find the right bead. So you
want to give it time to just search around in the solution,
find the right bead and bind there. And that, that takes time.
>> I see.
>> It takes time just based on quickly
the DNA moves around and how tightly it binds.
>> and what do you use to measure the results? Are you, I
mean are you just like snappin a picture of the chip? what's actually happening?
>> Yes. It's very close to that. in essence, you'd get
what's called a fluorophore attached to the, the bead. Because of the
presence of the A or the G at that position. that's the red or
green signal. You shoot a laser at it to excite the therafore, and then you
take a photograph of it with a digital camera. So a lot of it is
very much, you know, digital camera based.
Just interesting that that technology allowed our technology.
>> Yeah. And it also sounds like, I know how big
my digital camera picture files are, that sounds like it's a
lot of data, a lot of information that, that you end up with.
>> Yeah, so all of that data from
this giant image file gets processed by software
that's actually done by our labs in Los
Angeles, and translated into the xy plot I
mentioned before. Because for each bead on the
chip really all we're interested in is how
much red is there in there, and how
much green. The photograph itself is not terribly
useful after you extracted that data.
>> Well it sounds still like there is a lot of stuff
that goes on time from the time that you guys get the
wrong data and you sort of do your quality control, qc check
before you know you know i see it on my twenty three
[UNKNOWN]
profile page I mean is, is all of
that just sort of computational biology at that
point. who, who's looking at that data? Who's
organizing it? What's sort of going on there?
>> Yeah, it really becomes a computational biology problem once
we get the data from the lab, and that's really
where 23andMe concentrates most of our Staff here are computational
biologists or software engineers, so that's really where we're best.
so, the next major component there is called
calling, that's turning the data that we get
from the lab into the AAs, AGs or GGs that you can download in your raw data,
or produce the reports you see on our
website. and that's kind of an involved process but
it, in essence, relies on looking at these
xy plots and making sure that everything is where
it, we expect it to be.
>> and so the final results that, that we get back seem to look so, so curated
and so, so official w-, I mean how much of the computational sort of side
of this is sort of deriving you know. Oh what does this letter mean. I mean
how do you, I mean are you guys
viewing all the literature and, and selecting things and,
>> How, how are those decisions made in general?
>> So
we actually have a pretty big content team at
23andMe, they're the ones who scour the literature, look
at what's going on in the current science of
genetics, and find out, oh this mutation or this varient
causes this disease, and it's a new discovery. Then
they would write up what they think about that,
and try to put it in launguage that makes
sense to our users. And if it meets our scientific
criteria, it goes out to the website. It
is a little automated, and it can take time
to just process the data through to the website.
But the actual process of taking your data, calling
all the variance, and all that is quite
quick. You can think of the website as being
in two parts. There's the part where we just
look at the calls that you have for disease.
And the report just links that call to the
results. So for example we could say, you are
a carrier of cystic fibrosis because you have this
variant. So that's a, that's a scientific challenge, to
figure out what's going on in the literature. But
it's not an algorithmic challenge. The other part of
the website includes things like our ancestry composition feature
and our relative finder feature. Those are difficult algorithmic problems.
You want to take the whole, you know genotype sample all million variants and
try and figure out based on that, what is this person's ancestral composition.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So you can imagine that that's actually a more complex task and requires
a lot of code taking it from, you know, ABC through to the end